君たちは子供の頃どんなおもちゃで遊んでいたかい？
俺はねブロックと虫取り
それだけ
たぶんね子供のころどんなおもちゃで遊ぶかによって
たぶんその人はどのような人間になれるか
想像力とか才能とか溢れると思うんですけども
そういうひらめきをなんかこう
大切にするおもちゃがありますよね
こういう虫のおもちゃみたいです
こういう虫を作れるんですけども
8個のパーツがあるんですけども自由に組み合わせてなんか作れるみたいでございます
もうすごいねなんかプログラミングみたいな感じらしいっすよ
パーツくっつけて虫を作るんですけど
パーツによって走る場所が変わると
で　そうすると自分でね移動の仕方が考えられるんで
ルートを作れるらしいです
プログラミングロボってことですからね　こいつは
三歳から六歳ですからね（対象年齢）
わし（はじめ）が赤子のときはこんなものはなかった
時代の進歩を感じるんですけども
とりあえず一個開けてみましょう
（箱を開ける音）
おぉーうわぁぁーー
これか
うわぁ　びっくりしたぁ
ハァァ　ちょっと待てｗｗ
ほんとにびっくりした
もう電池入ってるパターンね
一応出ましたこの子ですね
で　これをですね　体これ離せるんでしょう？
おぉぉ
こうゆう感じでですねUSBのケーブルになってます
で　ここに
これも全部離れるんでしょう？
っわすごいな！これ
でたとえばこれをつけるとまっすぐ進むと
（虫の電子音）
（虫が出す陽気な音楽）
（虫が落ちる音）
これとこれをつけるとずっとグルグル回転するのかな
（虫の出す陽気な音楽）
ほら
グルグル回るようになります
思ったんですけども
８個↗のパーツしかないんですよね　普通に買うと
８個のパーツしかないので今回
よらぁぁぁ
そんなうれしそうな音出さないで
今回なるべくこの虫さんのおもちゃを買ってみました
これ説明書に載ってないんでわかんないんですけども
ひょっとしたら
ひょっとしたらこの虫さん８個以上つけても動くんじゃないかと思いまして
今回はもう史上最強に長い
超ロングなプログラミングいもむしロボットを作って
もっとこう想像力溢れる子供たちに俺は未来を見せたいんすよ
なるべくもう誰も見たことのない超長いロンｇ
（虫の電子音）
うるさい
もう誰も見たことのない超ロング
プログラミングロボットを作って
その最強のいもむしを今日僕の家で走りまわさせすしゅつ
では　いこうっ！
（虫の電子音）
キラリ－－ン（効果音）
はい　とゆうわけで全部のパーツが出ました
えぇと８×６＝４８だから体のパーツだけで４８パーツあります
とゆうわけでちょっとこの子の体になるべくたくさんのパーツをつけていこうと思います
これ何個まで乗る（付けられる）のかなぁ？
パーツ８個しかないって書いてあるんで
全部付けたらそうなるのかって言われるとわかんない
（虫の音）
ううぇ
ひとまずちょっと右に曲がるパーツだけ付けてみましょうか
落ち着け　落ち着け
かっ
あぁぁ　ごめんよ
おぉ
おぉぉ
おぉぉぉ
おぉぉぉぉ
おぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ
おぉ
わあぁぁ　わあぁ　わあ
１２３４５６７８
あぁ　これからだ
この先がいくかどうかで決まりますからね8個以上　　　　プログラミングできるかどうかが
ほあぁ　あぁ　はあぁ　はあぁ　いった　いった
はあぁぁぁぁぁ
はあぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
すごい　すごい
ういぃぃぃぃぃぃぃ
（虫の電子音）
うえぁぁ　ごめんごめん
すでにこの長さのいもむしができました
ちょっと走らせてみましょうか
（虫の電子音）
えぇ　マジですごいよこれ
だって説明書に何にも書いてないんですよ
実際つないで見たらちゃんと動きました
はいとゆうわけでちょっと
残りのパーツも全部くっつけて
４８パーツぐらい作れると思うんでちょっと
巨大ないもむしをとりあえず作りましょう
あなたは休憩
長さ的にはこれくらいの長さになっちゃいましたｗｗ
これ俺よりでかいんじゃない？
俺よりぜんぜん長いよもう
とゆうわけでちょっとこいつを今から走らせてみようと　　　思います
では早速つけてみましょう
くるか？
きた　きたきたきたきた
きたきたきたきたきたきたきた
すべてのスイッチが入っております
えっ！？
なになになに？
えぇぇ
ちょ
まっちょ
おまちょ
まさかおま
ヘフヘフヘフヘフヘフヘフヘフ
（悲しいBGM）
はい　とゆうわけでちょっと
（虫の音）
うるさい
はい　とゆうわけでちょっと残念ながら
超巨大ないもむしは作れなかったんですけど
まぁ　8個以上のやつは作ｒ
うるい（うるさい）
8個以上のやつをつなげても動くってことが分かったのはもう　うれしかったです
とゆうわけで最後はですね
まぁ　そこそこ長いいもむし4体を綺麗に動かしてね最後は綺麗に動画を終わりたいと思います
よし　お前たち最後　もうひとっ走り
いってこようZE☆
そうゆうときだけ黙るのね
（虫の電子音）
字幕見ていただいてありがとうございました